in the previous lecture we introduced
random variables probability mass
functions and expectations in this
lecture we continue with the development
of various concepts associated with
random variables there will be three
main parts in the first part we defined
the variance of a random variable and
calculated for some of our familiar
random variables basically the variance
is a quantity that measures the amount
of spread or the dispersion of a
probability mass function in some sense
it quantifies the amount of randomness
that is present together with the
expected value the variance summarises
crisply some of the qualitative
properties of a probability mass
function in the second part we discussed
conditioning every probabilistic concept
or result has a conditional counterpart
and this is true for probability mass
functions expectations and variances we
define these conditional counterparts
and then develop the total expectation
theorem this is a powerful tool that
extends our familiar total probability
theorem and allows us to divide and
conquer when we calculate expectations
we then take the opportunity to dive
deeper into the properties of geometric
random variables and use a trick based
on the total expectation theorem to
calculate their mean in the last part we
show how to describe probabilistically
the relation between multiple random
variables this is done through a so
called
joint probability mass function we take
the occasion to generalize the expected
value rule and establish a further
linearity property of expectations we
finally illustrate the power of these
tools through the calculation of the
expected value of a binomial random
variable